les films sont des rêves
[Musique]
que vous n'oublierez jamais
sammy
[Musique]
les lumières changent l'apparence de tout
il est difficile de trouver notre maison
marécage la maison sombre sans lumière
dans cette famille ce sont les scientifiques
contre les artistes
sammy de mon équipe prend après moi
[  Musique]
quel genre de film nous allons faire
[Musique]
vous rejetez ce qu'il fait c'est ludique ou
imaginatif
vous pourriez vous permettre d'être un peu
encourageant
elle aurait dû être pianiste de concert
ce qu'elle a dans son cœur c'est ce que vous
avez vous  tu ne peux pas juste aimer quelque chose tu
dois aussi en prendre soin c'est plus
important que ton passe-temps
peux-tu arrêter de l'appeler un passe-temps
maman a un singe
pourquoi as-tu eu un singe parce que j'avais besoin
de rire
et tu dois toujours être le  centre d'
attention arrête de lui crier dessus ça n'a
été qu'un manque de respect de ta part je suis
ta mère l'
art de la famille
ça va te déchirer
arrête de faire des films qui vont briser
le cœur de ta mère
je ne sais plus quoi faire
tu fais  quel est ton coeur  dit que vous devez
quelle était votre partie préférée
[Musique]
vous